حسنًا،
برنامج الغذاء العالمي، مستودع المساعدات في
غزة،
أشخاص يجمعون المواد الغذائية الأساسية مثل
دقيق العدس والحمص
وزيت الزيتون المنتج محليًا
وتشتريه الوكالة لتوزيعها على
المحتاجين
من الفلسطينيين، أربعة فلسطينيين
يعتمد حوالي عشرين ألف شخص على
المساعدات الغذائية من مركز التوزيع هذا
من بين مركزي المعونة التابعين لبرنامج الأغذية العالمي في
غزة حيث تزيد نسبة البطالة عن 45
بالمائة، لكنهم قد يعانون من
الجوع قريبًا نظرًا لأن برنامج الغذاء العالمي نفسه
ينفد من أموال المانحين.
الناس مثل أكثر سخونة خضير يعمل يومًا
أو يومين في الشهر في البناء
ويكسب أقل من  ثلاثون دولارًا
لا تكفي لشراء حتى كيسًا واحدًا من
أكياس الدقيق هذه، وهو
عنصر أساسي لإعالة أسرته المكونة من 10 أفراد.
أطفاله الثمانية على قيد الحياة يعملون،
ابنة متزوجة وأخرى معاقة واثنان لا يزالان
في المدرسة،
وابن واحد يعمل تاجرًا في السوق
ولكن  أبناؤه الثلاثة الآخرون عاطلون عن العمل
أه
برنامج الأغذية العالمي معرض لخطر نفاد
الأموال بالفعل مما يقلل من كمية المساعدات التي
يقدمها ويحذر من أنه بحلول
شهر نوفمبر سيضطر إلى تعليق
عملياته في غزة والضفة الغربية إذا
لم يتم توفير المزيد من التمويل
سيكون اجتياز ذلك بمثابة كابوس لسمر
البيوك التي تتسوق في المتاجر المعتمدة من برنامج الأغذية العالمي
ببطاقة صادرة عن
وكالة الإغاثة بدلاً من الحصول على السلع
من أحد المستودعات
وتعيل أسرة مكونة من سبعة أفراد،
ويعني برنامج الأغذية العالمي 8 أنها تستطيع شراء اللحوم
والجبن والملح حتى المربى  والشوكولاتة
لأطفالها
حتى وقت قريب، كان برنامج الأغذية العالمي يدعم
275,000 شخص في غزة بهذه الطريقة،
ولكن مع نفاد الأموال، قاموا أولاً
بخفض المبلغ الذي يحصل عليه كل مستلم،
ثم بدأوا في قطع الطريق عن الناس
تمامًا،
ولا تعرف البيوك ماذا ستفعل
وإذا حدث لها ذلك،
فهي ليست وحدها، حيث
يكافح اثنان من كل ثلاثة من سكان غزة الذين يزيد عددهم عن مليوني نسمة لتوفير الطعام لأسرتهم،
وما لم يقدم المانحون مبلغ 41
مليون دولار، الذي تقول وكالة المعونة إنها
تحتاج إليه للفلسطينيين بحلول شهر تشرين الثاني/نوفمبر في
غزة والغرب.  قد لا يكون لدى البنك
برنامج الغذاء العالمي لمساعدة
ريتشارد جرين سي إن إن غزة